[Musique]
pour les vacances de noël
je vais aller chez moi je vais bien
dormir dans ma chambre que j'ai décoré
je vais bien m'amuser avec mon frère je
vais avoir un beau cadeau à noël on va
aller au restaurant soir va manger
debout aux escargots des huîtres long
terme des fondamentaux
parce que la première fois que j'ai
mangé un salut est il un gros veulent
justement le cafard nous dit c'est pas
la peine de pleurer tu vois retrouve et
hammerson qui est un poil ça se calme je
commence à m'habituer
[Musique]
danse l'armée à l'emploi parce que je
pensais
et puis je cours cela arrive parce que
sinon cela trempé
les grands honneurs qu'ils ont
l'habitude de mâcon s'il y en a qui sont
moins depuis trois ans 85 ans il appuie
sont venus et l'accès à l'eau et quand
ils sont sortis ils étaient goût je
m'appelle lors du g 10 ans je m'appelle
à la voix si je suis passionné j'aime
pas tellement sort
à chaque fois que je mets mon garçon
saison elle existe 300 moyens chaque
fois que j'ai demandé aux garçons c'est
un indice il l a jamais rien qui m'ont
dit non
en général on terminèrent ils ont raison
et s'il nous mettant parfois on sait
qu'ils ont raison mais ce n'est pas en
effet ils travaillent très tard ils ont
pas le temps de donner à manger
on n'a pas envie de parler quoi un mot
spla durent quoi nous laisserait sa tout
dix minutes d'un petit peu le bavardage
tu peux de bavardages toulois chaque
soir quand on est sage du tout petit peu
le bazar d'âge datant du chlore amour je
place
je suis en pension parce que j'avais eu
mon retard il ya le grison pensionnaires
pour de 13 ans il ne sait pas ce que nos
parents sont divorcés
il l'est parce que leurs parents sont
morts il y en a pour deux raisons mousty
[Musique]
oui ici bref je sorte avant de voir la
vidéo me descendu ferme
vous allez me rappeler ce que c'est
qu'un verre il ya beaucoup de sorte de
fait c'est bien des couples bien bonjour
vite on essaie de se faire piquer ton se
fait piquer on a des policiers où l'on
regarde vers 6 rien sonore et quand ils
sont pas l'air un peu non profit on est
content quand on met une lettre aux deux
fois les joies que le courrier arrive je
suis heureux je m'avance pas de
plurielles j'écoute bien plus convenable
quand je mens calcul y est je me remets
à penser après ma mère moi c'est une
manière elle ne reprendra une heure
figurent également voir et des lettres
ben j'aimerais bien précis mélange
jamais l'être ne faisant pas le temps de
travail sa pâle pas maquillé
or
je ne sais pas lire
tout accord vraiment gentil pour
peut-être un petit petit vélo et ça peut
tuer ce match tu vas bien enfin
cependant loi et merci
renault qui en vaille la gaule pour la
première fois les romains la roma qui
était le chef de romain charles evans
justin
en
je voudrais que les coûts soient dehors
avec des coupes
je pense à mon copain gala et daniel
pion pas d'ego qui je vous demande de
laurent laurent laurent à quoi tu penses
c'est vrai souvent je pense à autre
chose
le m hidi que je rêve
la maîtresse aussi pense que je rêve
[Musique]
manquer ce que j'aime bien c'est les
frites tous les lundis je mange des
carottes et de pommes de terre n'est que
de la bonne viande du veau
il faut manger des pommes de terre avec
de la sauce tomate des fois mort dépens
de carey de la salade
il faut monter found été ressentie comme
des six à lait de la crème chocolat au
quartier al arani ou alors des gâteaux
ou alors une mandarine ou alors une
pomme ou en appelle aux anges
aujourd'hui nous allons étudier
l'addition avec classée encore en place
345 +72 et ses comptines coût serait de
cloud à 8,2 ils font vraiment beaucoup
de fois
mais j'aime bien la classe il y en a qui
sont collé quand il parle il peut pas
rester tout un souvenir les copains
stagne moi mon rêve c'est d'aller à
l'école à vélo et manger avec mes
parents billy et puis chéquier à la
maison quoi
note bien même sans vélo si je
retournerais à la maison pour manger et
coucher je serai content moi quand je
serai là aussi j'ai des enfants je ne
voudrais pas intention à quatre hommes
mangent un morceau de pain en personne
baguette et un bol de café ça fait envie
samedi on fait comme d'habitude
jusqu'aux heures et demie 11h30 devant
récréation ils nous appellent pour
manger on va manger après en une
récréation vite on pourra ses valises on
attend l'autobus comme le top 12 qui y
arrive on s'en va chez nous est arrivé
chez nous on joue
[Musique]
quand on part on est très heureux on à
samedi après midi et dimanche pour être
avec nos parents
[Musique]
il paraît qu'en 1940 pensionnaires ici
les 240 à tant de zones dit mélanie ça
recommence
[Musique]